my fellow Americans tonight I want to
talk to you about Syria
here are four takeaways from Obama's
speech on Syria I determined that it is
in the national security interests of
the United States to respond to the
Assad regime's use of chemical weapons
through a targeted military strike
nothing has been advanced in Sunday we
have no real timetable or no real
understanding of what's going to happen
next and why I will not put American
boots on the ground in Syria I will not
pursue an open-ended action like Iraq or
Afghanistan Secretary of State John
Kerry has promised that the action would
be unbelievably small but he also leaves
open a big window for boots on the
ground what's it gonna be we still don't
know and there are plenty of
contingencies that are unclear the
situation profoundly changed though on
August 21st
when Assad's government gassed to death
over a thousand people including
hundreds of children hundreds of
thousands of people have died because of
bullets and bombs in Syria what isn't
that trigger a humanitarian intervention
if in fact the United States is called
to respond into police various aspects
of the world's geopolitical situations I
believe we should act that's what makes
America different that's what makes us
exceptional isn't invoking American
exceptionalism the height of cynicism on
the part of Obama whose administration
and supporters have always attacked
Republicans like Sarah Palin or John
McCain for invoking that as one of the
reasons why America has to be everywhere
fighting everybody's battles all the
time for reason TV I'm Nick Gillespie